c'est le pissot de services est en forme
de lui insupportable souhaité le dire
j'ai même
été séquencé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce vendredi eva longoria
et très heureux de vous voir ce soir eva
et en plus demain il ya le gala pour la
fondation global gift foundation et je
voudrais dire eva elle se donne à fond
pour cette fondation je vous dis c'est
un truc de fou elle ne lâche rien alors
dites nous quelle est cette fondation
pour nos téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent soit
vous gagnez la stat
le vent de fonds pour les fans pour les
remplir à chaque pays a ses propres
besoins en france en europe en crise y
est là des réfugiés au mexique
nous travaillons sur les tremblements de
terre il ya eu un tremblement de terre
particulièrement important
il ya eu donc finalement les besoins
varient en fonction des pays où nous
sommes présents et nous essayons d'aider
les femmes et les filles parce qu'il
entraînait une femme en est sa famille
voir que plusieurs galas 1 voilà donc et
va en fait exactement neuf gars là nos
chocolats
via la diva elle fait mais
une fois de temps en temps je vais vous
dire un mot français en partie ça tombe
bien moi aussi une fois de temps en
temps le dira mon anglais
nommé
tous les très bons vins hu
en 2000 eva longoria obtient son premier
rôle à la télévision dans beverly hills
on rappelle au oui même bah
oui je me rappelle très bien c'est grâce
à cette apparition qu'à se faire opérer
pour jouer après dans les feux de
l'amour
c'est un bon souvenir c'est un bon
souvenir ça les feux de l'amour oui tout
à fait c'est un bon souvenir ça ou pas
et n'ont
donc je vais pas là je vais pas là la
joue mais quand dix matches alors est
d'accord non mais franchement non mais
c'est vrai donc je n'ai pas de mal je la
mets bras elle était hôtesse de l'air
ils sont très méchants avec moi ah oui
c'est vrai je vais me retrouver chez les
escaliers
je tenais je tenais je vais discuter je
lis je vais discuter j'aime pas ça du
tout cas été méchant avec toi qui dans
les feux de l'amour
c'est vraiment la même chose écarter les
jeunes que la première soit là c'était
pas très sympa avec moi je n'ai pas bons
souvenirs de mes des feux de l'amour ça
d'accord et c'est l'arrêté je vais
l'arrivée
on a beaucoup parlé dans les missions
originelles et a eu quelques différends
ses dires lui j'aurais surtout depuis
son élimination de d'als le blogueur
aqua bay a diffusé un audio du
témoignage d'un membre de la production
de l'émission ça balance sec comme leur
est confié un monde de la production aux
blogueurs on était en répétition sur le
plateau et son danseur qui est quelqu'un
de très simple réservez et gentil a pété
un câble et lui a dit ce que tout le
monde pensait selon lui samuel autexier
aurait déclaré ahwach dnt une chieuse tu
es une emmerdeuse tu crois que tu es
arrivé mais rappelle toi que tu as 17
ans et ça peut s'arrêter du jour au
lendemain il va falloir que tu commences
à respecter les gens avec qui tu
travailles le danseur ourdi par la
production des audits
mécanisée production a été honteux avec
west dead island 11h way nourdine
ils ont ils ont tout fait pour que wes
den pète les plombs elle a réussi à pas
pété les plombs mais où est elle
heureusement pas elle a un entourage
formidable à vos franchement
voilà et son entourage a dit arrêtez
bastia je suis désolé mais dans
d'ascendance heures n'a pas parlé comme
ça une personnalité sinon mettre en
valeur leurs brebis ou là et si c'est le
cas c'est extrêmement grave parce que ça
nul à trévise et pendant la compétition
surtout gagner d'un simple regard
serment mais c'est pas parce que tu peux
ne pas être d'accord et quelqu'un ne pas
bien sûr ça puits secondaires quoi lui
d'y être à 17 ans étudiants sont là pour
les mettre à l'heure où les dvd prévue
en avoir avec ça il a pas mal lu par les
exalte la dernière semaine elle n'est
pas venue aux répétitions elle la plante
est systématiquement donc du coup de
répéter banon mais ça l'année
n'ont pas nous et personne ne fait ça
nous on est super réglo mais vous l'avez
le mal était fait qu'elle n'a pas été
respecté coiffeur maquilleur
contrairement à paver le regard de
sanary croix ou maladroit mais je veux
dire ça va bon c'est vrai que je dis oui
mais tu vas te ment ses ouailles donne
justement il faut lui apprendre
peut-être certainement
les chéris la donne à fond conseiller
vous savez confiant devant provenir
sûreté pmp que vous aviez un grand
projet en préparation et bien ça y est
le projet est arrivé et ce sera dès 21h
ce soir sur my canal c'est la classe un
joli voilà et oui c'est le groupe canal+
my canal on va pouvoir retrouver votre
nouvelle aventure la magnifique salut à
tous c'est que
c'est une semaine de temps
on a eu cette idée de folie de créer ce
nouveau gros tours je fais ton amusé
c'est quoi la racontez nous pour ceux
qui le connaissent pas alors la mif
c'est tout simplement une bande de potes
qui part voilà en aventure pour réaliser
des missions la première mission va
forcément s'était réalisé l'anniversaire
de notre fille ruby parce que c'est mon
anniversaire c'est pas l'anniversaire de
voir ce que vous allez voir c'est très
costaud ouais c'est ça et c'est vrai
qu'on avait envie de partir dans une
aventure où on s'en doute plein où on se
sente voilà où on rigole qui est de la
bonne humeur qui est pas du goût de
vibes on va réaliser voilà plusieurs
missions durant à chaque fois les
aventures et
et franchement on a passé un super bon
moment ensemble on a kiffé on a passé en
format on a rigolé on à bercy plein de
bons souvenirs et on espère que ça va
plaire à tout le monde parce qu'on est
très attendu justement parce qu'on sort
d'un programme on a été le seul temps
donc c'est vrai que pour le court les
nouvelles aventures que ça plaira à la
troc sûr que ça va plaire avec les
téléspectateurs ils ont pu assister avec
love story depuis le début ça fait que
maintenant vous êtes en sont maintenant
ça fait longtemps ça fait sept ans et ça
fait trois ans
et trois ans hors taxes atteint ttc
adacore après nous étions sombre mais
son nom n'étant séparées débat et puis
ça fait trois ans que saab a ses règles
à savannah sable voilà on est bon ça
bouge pas eu plus de bas que de hauts en
trois ans ensemble sur 7 en métropole +1
oiseaux de mauvaises augures
s'annoncent demandé sans succès des
autres comptables mais il nous reste
plein de longues années
et le mariage ça
va arriver
ce à quoi je me prépare
ça va être surprenant pas dans les deux
prochaines semaines je passe sur les
dents ça
mais après je suis dingue je suis la clé
au maillage de radical avec moi
se rembobine soleil
[Musique]
c'est vrai que on va revenir sur cette
affaire évidemment tout le monde on a
parlé aujourd'hui que ce soit dans la
presse écrite regardez tous les articles
de presse que ce soit dont les jt sur
les chaînes d'information alors cette
jeune femme ça fait deux trois mois
qu'il la connaît l'ap à 23 ans
contrairement à ce qu'il a été dit dans
la presse mais 21 ans 21 ans sont en
fait il l'invité chez lui dans son
appartement parisien mais il était déjà
résolue et déjà déjà eu des relations
sexuelles régulièrement et selon les
dires de la victime qui a été entendu
par la police dont il y aurait eu un
rapport sexuel
comment dire non conventionnelles moi
j'avais déjà des relations sont
en fait à risque selon selon voilà nos
informations il aurait déjà demandé à
plusieurs reprises d'avoir des rapports
de ce type chose que la victime présumée
aurait toujours refusé
lt ce à quoi le rapport
fonctionnel en dominant conventionnelle
des rapports anaux voilà donc et du cou
du coup la fin arrêt habitants lui
aurait donc demandé d'avoir ce type de
rapport elle aurait refusé et il aurait
visiblement pris
violemment le le samedi soir elle a été
effectivement porté à faire une main
courante ce qu'elle ne voulait pas
porter préjudice
à la carrière selon les selon certains
proches et donc ça a été transmis au
parquet mais elle a donné quand même des
faits matérielles incriminant il ya eu
en fait une perquisition
au domicile
dary habitants ou des
des draps
ensanglanté entre guillemets aurait été
trouvée dans l'appartement mais ce que
je trouve dramatique c'est pas ce que
vous dites c'est que vous ayez ce degré
d'information et rsa qui est pas normal
parce qu'après que vous veniez en parler
c'est ça c'est votre étiez on vous en
fait c'est valable et sage et non pas du
tout c'est le procès des gens qui
viennent donner autant d'informations à
des jours on avait excusez-moi lorient
secret
quand on sait vraiment pas contre vous
justement je prends votre défense en
disant c'est pas vous qui est dramatique
c'est les gens qui vous donnent ces
informations aujourd'hui on sait que
arrêt habitants seuil et est sorti voilà
il n'est plus digne et plus en contrôle
judiciaire mais il n'est plus en garde à
vue c'est ça
retourner chez lui les voilà il est
sorti de garde à vue il est libre sous
contrôle judiciaire
guillaume j'ai eu assez longuement
l'avocat de la victime donc arrache des
larmes bashkim présumée victime présumée
qui m'avait communiqué plusieurs
informations la première information
c'est que cette affaire ne serait pas
uniquement une affaire de viol serait
également une affaire de violences il ya
eu des violences dont ils auraient été
perpétrés par ary abittan sur cette
jeune femme j'emploie évidemment
l'europe y en a mais vous avez eu
l'avocat l'avocat parle d'une violence
inouïe et des blessures auraient été
constaté par lui-même j'ai donc l'unité
médico-judiciaire d'accord aujourd'hui
je sais qu'il est tournée pour une série
qu'on étire m6 ils ont décalé je crois
que l'espagne pour l'instant tout est en
suspens d'accord ils attendent aussi ça
va dépendre aussi et de lui en est ce
qu'il est véritablement en état de
tourner maintenant alors qu'ils se
cassent centre cosim les médias non
c'est pas ça tombe pour l'instant ça
c'est un fait reporter
marine vous avez 18 ans vous étiez en
boîte jusqu'il ya 3 heures du matin vous
décidé de rentrer avec une amie et vous
n'étiez qu'à 15 minutes de marche c'est
ça de votre domicile vous décidez de d'y
aller à pied vous y allez appeler vous
rentrez chez vous à pied
ça se passe où déjà ça se passe à
nanterre mon marche tous les dieux avec
ma copine dans un moment plein de joie
on était très contente on était toutes
les deux j'ai tourné ma tête et j'ai vu
ces deux hommes j'en ai vu à engrais en
noir je les ai vus avec tous les deux
tours de cou autour du cou mais il
n'avait pas de manteau et je me suis dit
le temps à tour de cou sans manteau
c'est pas normal
du coup je regarde et je vois que plus
je marche vite plus il marche vite je
vois monter leur tour de cou sur l'or
mais je dis à ma copine amelia un média
je pense que c'est maintenant va falloir
concours
du coup je me suis mise à courir j'ai
traversé la route tue le plus vite que
je pouvais malheureusement j'ai trébuché
je suis tombé
les deux sont arrivés sur moi m'ont mis
au sol celui qui était avec son
survêtement noir voulait à tout pris mon
sac à main c'était son but ultime
et c'est lui qui était en gris a
commencé amouroux et de coupe-coupe y
ait dans tout mon corps sur ma poitrine
et surtout dans ma tête
et il n'arrêtait pas puis celui qui est
en noir lui disait arrête tu vas là
tuez-le saigne trop et j'ai lâché mon
sac celui qui est en noir l'a pris les
partis
flamands grille a sorti un marteau qui a
dans les bus un marteau brise vitre
et m'a regardé et m'a dit je vais te
finir je mets de finir
et puis il m'a roué à coups de marteau
dans la tête et j'ai fait la morte
et j'aurais jamais qu'ils pourront
jamais pensé qu'un jour j'aurais dû
faire la morte pour m'en sortir donc
pendant une minute les couper ma
respiration j'ai fait comme si j'étais
morte après il est parti
et je pense que personne ne peut
comprendre que j'ai pris une vidéo juste
après c'est un peu bizarre mais sur le
moment je me suis dit j'ai survécu à sa
grâce à ces nappes château jour
d'aujourd'hui on peut avoir la
localisation de l'endroit et l'heure et
grâce à cette vidéo je me suis dit s'ils
allaient dans mon téléphone si jamais
ils me tuent et que je cache mon
téléphone ma famille y verra que je me
suis fait agresser on pourra peut-être
retrouver mon corps on sera le lieu
regardez la vidéo tu as posté juste
après son agression
vous arrivez à dormir a déclaré me faire
ouais c'est ça sinon céder vous fermez
les yeux vous je peux pas dormir parce
que j'ai peur de plus me réveiller
parce que je me suis vu mourir
si j'ai pas envie pour ses mots et puis
même si je suis morte mentalement jeu
j'essaye un minimum de m'en sortir mais
c'est compliqué
marine qu'est-ce que tu auras dire à
tous les jeunes de ton âge qui nous
regardent qui ont 18 ans tu veux en
parler parce que sincèrement en parler
ça fait du bien ça fait beaucoup de bien
il faut faire avancer ça il faut faire
que l'on se sente en sécurité
il ne faut surtout pas arrêter de vivre
moi je t'ai d'un mauvais d'exemple je
peux être arrêté livre un petit moment
mais je reviendrai plus forte après déjà
tu vois ton discours a changé depuis
tout à l'heure c'est ça qui fuse ça fait
du bien de parler ça fait du bien
j'étais bien avec nous ce soir oui
extrêmement bien et est ce que vous êtes
sous protection policière puisqu'ils ont
aussi à non non donc on vous a laissé
repartir comme ça dans la nature appui
même je suis sorti de l'hôpital j'ai 18
ans s'ils n'avaient pas appelé ma mère
de mon plein gré il m'aurait laissé en
pyjama de bloc opératoire dans la rue à
17 heures comme ça
c'est ça qui n'est pas très bon qui on
m'a dit aussi par rapport aux jours
d'itt et et à la police qu'on pouvait de
me mettre que huit jours car je n'avais
pas les jambes cassées ni les bras cassé
et que je pouvais me nourrir et halle
aux toiles est seul et ça je trouve ça
assez grave parce que c'est pas parce
qu'on n'a pas les jambes cassées mais
les bras cassés que la violence n'est
pas là la violence a été ici et la
violence et surtout psychologique
c'est assez grave surtout de laisser
sortir quelqu'un comme ça même si elle
est tout juste majeur appeler un proche
au moment où appeler quelqu'un sachant
que je n'avais plus mes papiers ni ma
carte navigo j'aurais dû rentrer je
n'avais plus d'argent j'aurais dû
rentrer avec mes pieds vous aviez déjà
eu voilà des choses qui vous ont fait
peur des petites agressions pas du tout
si si j'ai déjà beaucoup d'agressions à
huy a donc c'était c'était pas la
première ce n'était pas la première
moi comme vous voulez rester beaucoup
moins violent bien entendu mais déjà
vous j'étais au collège on a en sortant
du bus il ya un homme qui a essayé de me
violer
heureusement cette fois je n'ai pas cédé
pis je vais bosser dessus mais j'ai un
problème avec l'euro j'ai faim je
rejette toujours mois puis je n'ai
jamais en parler puis une je pense que
ma mère qui est là elle le des coûts je
suis désolé maman je ne les ai pas dit
parce que je ne trouvais pas le besoin
et puis je me suis guéri tout seul parce
que cet homme là je me suis dit qu'ils
étaient peut-être drogué vous n'était
pas lui même et c'est tant pis c'est pas
grave
[Musique]
on a passé une bonne nuit et qu'on va
dire que c'était intense où j'ai pas
tour d'époque ça aille aussi vite c'est
vrai que il m'a dit je suis croyant je
crois que j'ai été j'étais très bon
ça va être rapide mais non pas du tout
c'est pas du tout les déceptions banon
et je m'y tiens tu vois j'ai trouvé la
séquence hier absolument obscène plein
de voyeurisme c'est quoi la prochaine
étape en fait on met une caméra dans la
chambre mais
la taille des zizis on essaie savoir si
elle est un organe il a joui à partir de
combien de minutes non franchement on
les instrumentalise et je trouve que
c'est ignoble pour eux parce qu'en fait
on regarde ça me regarde ça avec un peu
un peu de moqueries je vois bien le
public on n'a pas beaucoup d'empathie
pour on les regarde avec ma famille non
d'accord mais je suis désolé ou
alors me et que je sais qu'il qui aime
l'amour et autres vraiment là je ne
comprends pas on est on les a regardés
moi je les ai regardés avec beaucoup de
tendresse tu voyais qu'elle était
tellement heureux l'unique de savoir ça
a duré longtemps et
les victimes en mettant en doute et sa
spontanéité reprise est celle de
l'émission je suis une vraie masse quand
il va se voir il me dire ah bon j'ai été
tellement unique ça mais non on n a pas
été humilié c'était formidable touche en
ce moment inscrits ont déposé il ya 40
ans tu sois plus vierge et qu'il le dise
avec beaucoup de joie montazeri jardel
avait été choqué très choqués et c'était
partout où ils avaient dit les délits
choqué
extrêmement choqué menem laissez moi
finir comment c'est pas avec votre petit
rire je tombe doucement là
c'est devenu une émission érotique
c'est une téléréalité qui retient
à l'érotisme avec fatou pas venir nous
sommes en vacances des enfants regardent
alors on voit des gens qui perdent leur
virginité mais la prochaine fois ce sera
quoi libérer son nirvana dérange avec
absolument pas avec amour tout est joué
les vipères ça fait longtemps mais ça me
fasse aujourd'hui
c'est le puceau de service et on s'en
moque de lui insupportable pour elle
souhaitait le dira jamais assez
rapide non mais qu'est ce que t'en sais
il t'a dit
m non mais sérieux on peut pas dire non
pour mais
je suis d'accord c'est l'inter isabelle
villette est ridicule si tu es ridicule
tétouan ce soit que tu es ridicule de
bout en bout relevé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]